to the MVP
of the Eastern Conference Finals the
Larry Bird Trophy and Alonso
Jimmy Butler
[Applause]
[Music]
you know Jimmy
late in this late in our telecast
tonight in the fourth quarter they
replayed a clip from last year after the
Eastern Conference Finals when you said
a year from now we're going to be back
we're going to be in the same position
and we're going to get it done how did
you know that I have so much belief in
myself and this group of guys in the
squad that uh coach Pat and SPO and
everybody else put together I see it
every single day I know how good of
players that we have I know how good of
a team we are and we made it happen I
saw Pat Riley here moments ago and years
and years ago Jimmy when I had just
started at TNT which is about 30
something years ago I interviewed Pat
and he said in basketball there are two
things there's winning and there's
misery and you've experienced both now
in 48 hours how did you come back from
game six uh we we stayed together as a
group as a team we talked about going to
get a tough one on the road we did just
that but we're not satisfied we're
excited we're happy but we got four more
to get
your old college coach Buzz Williams he
and I were swapping texts and I asked
him about coaching you and what made you
special at that point he said it was an
uncanny basketball IQ and it was never
being satisfied you just you just
referred to that too so how does that
how does that translate into an NBA
Finals appearance against the Denver
Nuggets I mean more than anything I
think Buzz taught me to rely and trust
my teammates with everything I do the
same thing here with SPO my teammates
give me so much confidence and believe
to go out there and just hoop at a high
level I'm so very appreciative and
grateful for them and they're the reason
why we're winning games you hope at a
high level tonight I congratulate you
nice going and good luck in the finals
both thank you too very much here are
your Eastern Conference champions
heading to the NBA finals against the
Denver Nuggets the Miami Heat